[Music]
joining me today is an author a radio
and podcast host and the executive
chairman of the Iran Institute you're on
Brooke welcome back to the Rubin report
thanks thanks for having me back
normally I don't let people back but I'm
willing to make an exception I
appreciate that all right we got a lot
to talk about and first I'm going to
tell a little bit of a story that that
you know and for those that watched the
stream that I did a toke on which is the
objector conference in Pittsburgh last
month I told the story but I just want
to reiterate a while I'm sitting here
with you now that you are on this show
for the first time in May of 2016 so
about year and three months ago or so
and I was in the midst I had just sort
of been thinking about maybe leaving or
a TV which is the network that we were
on a place that I loved being at that
Larry King had brought me into that I
felt we were growing and all that but at
the same time I realized we were growing
so rapidly there was so much happening I
wanted to own and control what I was
doing and all this stuff I sit down with
you lay out rational self-interest you
lay out the tenets of Objectivism you
lay out a lot of issues about capitalism
and taxes and all of these things and I
finished that interview like said
goodbye do we shook hands and I walked
into the control room and I said to my
guys I think it's time to go I hope
you're going to come with me
fortunately they all did come with me we
ended up going on patreon became fans
funded that's over a year ago now the
rest is history so I do connect some of
my current success to sitting down with
you in the first place well I appreciate
that and and thanks for telling the
story and it was it was fun because I
think I got a phone call from you either
that day and my joy as I'm driving all
night a day certainly within the day
within it within a day or two saying you
know I'm leaving yeah and you're very
courageous of you and I'm thrilled that
it worked out so amazingly well yeah you
must love I'm sure that's not a first
time that you know someone listen to you
speak and then it affected the way they
actually opted not just the way they
think that that's the important thing
I've had many guests come in here
that affect the way I think make me
think different things or change my
thoughts or sometimes it reinforces the
thought whatever it is but you must
appreciate that more than it helps when
someone goes I heard you and let me put
this stuff into action yes I mean when
somebody comes and says I heard you and
as a consequence of that I did XYZ and
it changed my life there's nothing more
satisfying as a teacher as a lecturer as
a you know as a commentator than having
something like that 9r and got a lot of
that right she changed my life she
changed everything about what happened
in my life but but for me as you know
I'm not an originator of ideas I'm over
communicative of ideas it's incredibly
satisfying it's it's it's it's the
funnest thing that happens so we're
going to talk about a lot of stuff here
what I what I don't want to do is I
don't want to just focus on the same
ideas of Iran that we discussed the
first time we will link to our original
interview below so shrimpo want the full
catch up we're going to do a little bit
but I don't want to just you know
repackage what we did last time so I
thought the best place to start off is
that most of my audience knows I am
doing monthly events with you guys with
a RI where we're really focusing on free
speech and I've been usually with Steve
Simpson
and then we brought a few people that
I've done shows with with better Michael
Shermer and Colin Moriarty and a bunch
of people we have Brett Weinstein coming
on working on a few others and when I
when they proposed this idea to me I
said well look if if we're going to
focus on free speech and really just
allow us to say whatever we want and
talk about why that's important to do it
how does free speech fit into
objectivism into Iran's ideology and
into your ideology well it's it's a
cornerstone of the ideology in terms of
the application of it objectivism is
about reason it's about using your mind
it's about using your mind and the
ability of our senses and our mind to
discover reality we need to be able to
express that in some way through action
through speech writing books writing
articles we need to be able to
communicate those truths that we
discover and the human mind is capable
of knowing the world but if it just
stays in the mind what's the point
and if they are salaries out it they can
tell you no no that idea is unacceptable
you have to be in house arrest in the
case of gallows oh oh we can actually
burn you at the stake
then you're shutting down the human mind
people will not think now it's true that
it's part of the freedom to speak but
think a lot of bad ideas are going to
come up right a lot of untruths a lot of
garbage fine but in order to strike
towards truth you're going to have to
let a lot of untruth be told we thought
we wouldn't be discussed you cannot
establish Authority the dictates what is
good what is true what is not true the
ultimate authority is reality
yeah are there any ideas that are too
dangerous to explore so when we've seen
bad ideas really truly bad ideas the
Holocaust is our Network into action
this started as an idea of course
heading and absolutely but but it's
taught as an idea in in the writings of
a philosopher in in my view you know 150
years before the Holocaust like but the
fact is really rich philosophers well I
think it's Immanuel Kant I think that
the guy who separates human reason from
reality the guy who says that morality
is about duty and who says that he's
trying to save faith save faith from the
tyranny of reason if you were is the
amount of content I think he begins the
long chain of Hegel and Schopenhauer and
Marx and Nietzsche that ultimately leads
I think to the Nazi ideology but the
fact is that the only way to combat
Kant's the only way to combat Marx the
only way to combat Nietzsche the only
way to combat any of these ideas is what
better ideas is is is to engage once you
establish an authority that says no
can't you're going to lead to Hitler one
day we have to silence you right then
you're already establishing what Hitler
wants you're establishing the authority
of you know somebody's mind over other
people's minds and that's what that's
what has to be banned it's so
interesting because there's a
if there's a play here that I think goes
well for for you guys as Objectivist
which is anytime someone brings up an R
and there's the select group of people
that like her that like the ideals they
want to hear that now but for most
people at least in the mainstream
there's an immediate dismissal oh that's
that child is stuff I all know that nice
school or college or blah blah and it's
all that is it's not a debate of ideas
that's just a shutdown of discussion
which is the complete reverse of what
you want and exactly and look if
somebody who advocates for radical ideas
and my ideas are radical the different
from the mainstream the different what
people out they believe I have to have
free speech in order to be able to
advocate and be able to hopefully change
the world for the better and advocate
for the kind of ideas that I believe it
true and and real and if we allow
anybody to shut down ideas I'm going to
be among the first victim so I have a
clear selfish interest in advocating for
free speech and in viewing I'm and
viewed free speech as if free speech
goes then it softer or Terina so my free
speech goes what is your only option
right the only option then to fight for
whatever you believe in is with a fist
it's with a gun it's revolution so free
speech as though it is is a recognition
that the only way we are going to change
the world is through discussion through
reason to fact without the use of fists
and guns as soon as that is gone as soon
as that is eliminated all that's left is
is violence and and that's of course you
know what we see on campuses what we're
seeing is the resorting to violence
because they've given up on reason
they've given up on speech they've given
up on discussion I don't know if you saw
this but about a month and a half ago
there was an article written in der
Spiegel about me and a few other people
and it was talking about this the rise
of the new alright which couldn't be
more absurd yes but I spent the entire
day with the author he watched me do two
shows here and then the evening was at
UCLA where I did an event with the I
nine folks and I was on with with Colin
and and the way he wrote it was that we
were at some sort of far-right
angry rally and I thought the video is
up there by the way their book and
watching me talk
nine ran into channel page and it's like
people watch it this thing could not
have been a more joyous expression of
free speech but but even that shows you
what we're up against just this constant
miss truth throughout the media right
now that that's eroding our ability to
accept what facts are absolutely and
look I'm fine with dealing with miss
truths
because the truth will went out and we
can debate that what worries me is an
op-ed in the New York Times a few weeks
ago that came out that said explicitly
that speech is violence that is scary
right because as soon as they say you
know so they call you an outright what
you know and you say I'm not and fine
but once they say okay your ideas
equivalent to violence what they're
legitimizing is using violence against
you and that is what is really truly
dangerous in this debate and that's
what's going on in Berkeley and
evergreen and all these other places
where the left these students feel
emboldened to being up baseball bats
yeah not to defend themselves against
somebody else who has a gun who has a
was another baseball bat but defend it
to defend themselves against being
offended by somebody else's speech
they've given up on reason they've given
up a debate they've given up on the
human mind and what Dad what presents is
a return to primitive brutishness right
to tribal warfare because it's not an
accident that the postmodern is all
about tribalism right this is about what
terms of tribalism where we hit each
other instead of debating each other in
the great achievement of the Western
civilization and I really consider
Western civilization achievement of
Greece and achievement of the
Enlightenment and the great achievement
in the Enlightenment is saying stop
killing each other over all ideas right
because if you think about the 17th
century more people died per capita in
the 17th century than maybe any other
century certainly in modern history
because Protestants and Catholics were
slaughtering each other and the line
that said stop with the violence
violence is anti like anti man which we
should ban it if we disagree let's
discuss it and let and let reality be
the judge of what is true and what isn't
and we're abandoning that magnificent
achievement of enlightenment do you pin
all of that on post-modernism well look
yet yes in this modern format but again
post-modernism is a consequence of a
long string of ideas that in a sense
goes back to Plato right you know it
goes back to Plato but I consider Plato
innocent right because he was such a
genius and he was so early in human
beings thinking big thoughts like
thinking philosophical ideas then any
errors he made we can forgive I can't be
that angry of Plato no he can't get mad
appear now once you get into the modern
era I start getting angry at peopie is
that because they've got we've got human
history you can look you can see you've
got you've got lots of examples of what
happens when you have bad ideas but if
you think about Plato's ideas Plato
basically said that the truth is to be
found in a different dimension that the
world of forms is not the world was seen
so our senses our reason is not seeing
the world as it is and though we only
specialists call them philosophers can
actually see the truth so he has this
allegory of the cave where we're all in
the cave chained and all we see are
shadows and that's reality to us and
only if you go to the mouth of the cave
can you see the real world which is the
Sun only the philosopher can actually
see that that me is that we have to be
ruled by experts we have to be ruled by
these philosophers we have to be told
what reality is because we just to in a
sense and dumb or two we don't have the
revelation now that opens up there to
religion and everything right revelation
is choose versus reality issues I
attribute all of these bad ideas in a
sense back to that some illogical
falsehood I think and then the post
modernists have just taken that and
turned it into you know it made it much
much worse but in some respects
consistent how much of that do you think
is just the top-down way of viewing the
world versus the bottom-up meaning
top-down meeting through either God or
some sort of religious construct as
opposed to viewing everything from the
individual and from our own mind I think
it's all about that and and I think I
think it's basically the challenge is
what is human reason is is human reason
efficacious that's the fundamental
question and if you think about Plato
versus the Pierrot in my view
historically as Aristotle as Otto says
no reason is efficacious this is the
world we know the world by using our
senses and using our mind to understand
it now you not everything he said is I
think it's turned out right not
everything it says philosophic is right
was that subjective when he said that so
the person that's in the shackles
that's only seeing shadows that still is
their reality right it is but it's not
subjective in the sense that there is a
true reality she says there is a true
reality it's here this table actually
exists we're both you might see that
angle on it I might see this angle on it
but is if we use the tools of science we
can shake the table and agree on what
the table is and what it's composed of
and how it functions so that reality is
objective even though we might see
different sides of it our reality it is
it is objective and we have the tools
reason science to fully understand the
context of the table so for Aristotle
human reason and in our senses actually
reflect the reality as it is now again
he was influenced by Plato as a student
focusing fifteen years or something so
he was influenced by Plato so there's
some errors I think and whatever Stahl
advocates for bit but to me time and too
many thinkers I think the the real
battle of all Western history and
ultimately I think global history
because I think Western ideas are
spreading all over the world is a battle
between al estado and Plato between
whether reason is efficacious in this
world whether we see reality as it is
where the reality is objective where the
reality is independent of our
consciousness or whether you know we
need we need to to get knowledge from
some kind of other dimension that and
then you need the experts and then you
need the leaders and then you need you
need you know look if you look at Hitler
Hitler was just channeling
the truth for the Orient people to the
audience right he was the guy who had
the revelation if you will for the truth
today if you look at if you look at the
Communists well how do we know what the
politic need but you need somebody to
channel to get to somehow in some
mystical way to get to what is good for
the politician so you have a stall and
you have a Leonard you need a leader
you know I reject all of that Aristotle
would have rejected all of that you have
to discover the truth for yourself it is
your responsibility as a human being to
discover truth I mean you shouldn't have
to accept the truth over the barrel of
the gun you shouldn't have to accept the
truth of the value of a gun or over you
know over the kind of social pressure
that a church or communist party or
Hitler Youth kind of dictate to you you
should use your mind as an independent
human being to go out there and discover
what is real and what is not what is
right and what it's not and and and
discover the values that are going to
lead it might you might be the purpose
of morality is there is to lead to your
own happiness to discover the values
that are going to make your life the
best life that it can be make your life
objectively the best life that it can be
is anything that you've said so far that
you believe in not an Enlightenment
value because for example I've had
several people come on the show who are
believers and who would argue that this
comes from a judeo-christian mindset and
I think you can make all of the I think
there's errors in that way of thinking
of though I can appreciate it but I
think every argument that you've made
has really been about enlightenment
that's just that is that fair no
absolutely and look I think there are a
lot of Christians and Jews who would
like to take their Christianity and
Judaism and massage it so it fits into
the Enlightenment values which they the
good in them responds to but it isn't
there now they're elements right the you
wouldn't Christian II wouldn't read
successful if it didn't have an element
of individualism in it to your
relationship with God as an individual
relation Judaism would have survived all
the years if it ended Apted cleverly to
kind of enlightenment values and embrace
Aristotle Maimonides was a no still Yin
scholar so Judaism in some extent
embraced our style in different in
different stages so these religious
adapted and in one of the problems with
Islam is it didn't adapted it is
sticking to the the mystical dogma of
its founding rather than having adapted
to Aristotle to to these Enlightenment
vows but yes all these ideas are at the
very least hinted at in the
Enlightenment now I don't believe
they're fleshed out in the alignment I
think this is why when cons and
Schopenhauer and all of these guys who
are anti Enlightenment figures came
about the Enlightenment was weak in its
response because I don't think the
alignment had completely philosophically
fleshed out these ideas and I think that
it took Iran to really flesh out I view
Iran is philosophically the culmination
of the Enlightenment I think she's she
rep there's a true representative of
those Enlightenment ideas fully fleshed
out fully understood and the first time
the first thing that to really be able
to combat the ideas of a Hegel in it and
a Nietzsche and it marks an account and
and and and that's the power that's the
philosophical power that yeah but yes
it's all there right the Declaration
dependence even though Molly if you'd
ask any one of the founders or if you'd
asked the Enlightenment think is what is
the purpose of morality if they talk
about sacrifice and they talk about
altruism unity but in the Declaration
they chose to say that you have an
inalienable right to pursue you won't
have it yeah right so they understood
and they they had a deep understanding
of the idea of happiness as the as the
purpose of living as the purpose of life
if I'm not mistaken we're the only
country in the world perhaps in the
history of the world that has a line
like that right there is one of the
country okay you're going to blow my
mind now here is one of the country and
it was it they didn't they didn't choose
it
it was crammed down their throat the
only country actually can have it in the
Constitution is Japan and that's because
General MacArthur wrote a constitution
after World War two
the Japanese wrote a constitution
MacArthur said this is you know you have
to change all your ways you guys had a
bad idea G and bad ideas we crushed you
guys you have to change and basically
McLaughlin has assistant sat down and
they wrote
Japanese Constitution and in the
Constitution it says that you have any
nearly would like to pursue your
happiness and they basically forced it
down the empress throats and the
japanese have adopted it and I would
argue that Japan has succeeded as well
as it has succeeded because it basically
got a version of the American
Constitution do you think there's like a
little bit of a catch-22 with putting
happiness in a document like that like
on one hand it's like said you're
supposed to be happy in this is great we
all want to be happy we want to find out
if but on the other hand there's an odd
pressure that other country that other
countries up like in other countries you
work you do what you do you hopefully
pilfer some happiness out of existence
but with less it's baked in like there's
opportunity for happiness there maybe
have maybe the human condition at its
most honest it I don't know that it's
happy you're not happy it just is and
you got to grab it
pictures that a strife or something
right so it's not happiness that's
guaranteed in the Declaration but it's a
freedom yeah which is what a right means
what a rights mean right means freedom
of action so you have free to act in
pursuit of your happiness that's
beautiful yeah I can't think of anything
more beautiful in a political document
then that every individual has a right
to act you know to pursue the rational
values that are necessary for his own
happiness now I put in an additional
words in there but I think that's at the
end of the day what the phone is
actually meant they wanted to create a
country where individuals could go and
they would be free to act on their own
behalf
in rationally they didn't they want
crooks they don't want bad guys didn't
want lazy people they wanted people who
actually wanted a embrace life and go up
in in and achieve happiness and or at
least strive towards happiness and and
and do the best they could so you
mentioned that Iran is in your view the
philosopher who sort of pinned all this
together so now as I said without
redoing everything we did last time and
again we will link to it down below so
sometimes we forget and people get this
but we are going to link to it down
below can you explain to me in just a
couple of minutes yeah what it is that
Iran put together I know I know it but
for my audience what Iran put together
that you view as the complete package or
sort of the endgame of these
enlightenment values sure well let's let
so
put it in the context of the
Enlightenment the Enlightenment is still
to a large extent in both a you know
feels the pressure from Christianity so
Locke is still a a Christian or at least
claims to be and he's trying to
philosophically justify everything in
terms of Christianity and and even the
founders right as secular as I think
they were and as deist as they were they
were still they were still felt like at
least morality at least the certain
elements that they felt that they had to
be linked back to God which meant God
was mentioned a lot even though they had
a separation the declaration advances
creator you know it doesn't say God but
which I think was important to them but
but at the end of the day yes I mean if
you read the Federalist paper view to
other things they clearly a referencing
I caught the common understanding of
Christianity at the time I'm much more
secular understanding than 100 years
previous but it's still under the guise
of the religion Iran you know secular
rises those ideas completely so she
starts off by saying reality is what it
is that you know nature is out there
it's independent of our consciousness
each and this is good she goes to
Aristotle a is a this table is here
table is here and we can measure its
dimensions and we can understand it
scientifically and it is and we have the
ability to know the table right is here
you know use of our senses in Armonk so
our reasoning capacity tells us about
the world in its and she grounds and she
has a whole theory of concept formations
how we come up with a concept of table
and and how the mind in that sense works
there is a revolutionary that did not
existed before and really is missing
from from Lockean and the Enlightenment
philosophy this connection of
epistemology and metaphysics to the
politics and he says look reason reason
is it is a is a is a capacity of the
individual we don't have a collective
stomach we don't have a collective
consciousness we don't have a collective
mind so reason is something individuals
do and and she places the the core of
morality with the individual right so
your purpose as a human being Molly if
to survive as a human being which means
to use your reason in order to guide
your life towards the goal which is
happiness and she bridges what in
philosophy is called the is odd
dichotomy can you take what exists out
there the condition of man has existed
in reality any can you derive offs from
and she says of course you can we have a
particular nature now the study of
ethics is the study of what is that
nature therefore what other virtues and
values we need to adopt in order to stay
in existence because we face this
alternative as living beings of death
now we can go out of existence so she
bridges all of this and of course
connects all that ultimately to politics
so the biggest pushback I here against
that is that if it is all somehow just
left to us and left to our mind and
logic and reason all that that we the
mind plays tricks on us we all believe
different things we all get different
news sources we all are brought up in
different religions or non religions
whatever that the the system of so many
competing individuals will lead to some
sort of like mass chaos and something
well it turns out quite a contrary it
turns out when you leave people free and
you leave people free to think for
themselves you get beautiful things and
it is authoritarian it is their give of
an authority the idea of one way of
thinking of the world the idea of
cramming down our minds truth is what is
destructive to progress an ability to
innovate and create and build and make
the fact that we have different values
the fact that some people want to be
doctors and other people want to be
architects and other people want to be
high tech entrepreneurs creates the
beautiful world what we have to what we
have to accept I men would argue is that
morality right is objective just like
science teaches us about the physical
world morality should teach us about
what is good for us and what is bad for
us
from the perspective of human action
from human thought in human action that
there's certain things that are wrong
that it amol that evil that are bad and
when those things get translated into
action then yeah then the state needs to
intervene and take
people put them in jail but they're
going to be bad people who are Baptists
and as long as they don't manifest them
into action I can say that person seemed
all but I can't do anything about it
unless he acts in a way that hurts
somebody else did violate somebody
else's rights so I think you may have
seen this but I had an interesting
debate a couple weeks ago between
Michael Shermer from skeptic magazine
yes and Dennis Prager who's a
conservative arguing but for that the
necessity now for God to have a live a
moral life now pretty clear which side
you're on on this well but I disagree
with both right because I disagree with
schirmer's basis for establishing so
that allows why I wanted to get yeah so
he's too much of a skeptic in my view so
he rejects and this is the problem I
think with a lot of the new atheist is I
find them conventional when it comes to
morality and innocence the funny thing I
find it you know Harrison and Sherman
and the Elkin and Dawkins very Christian
in them all beliefs so they accept
Christian morality without attributing
of course to Christianity they accept
the the commandments if you will of
Christian morality without challenging
them and what would ran does what I
really what do you mean they accept them
as only as exposed to accepting them as
values of immediate lighting them as
opposed to be thinking as opposed to say
okay we got a blank slate right we're
going to take science and apply it to
morality
and so they accept for example the
sacrifice that selflessness is morally
good
you can't justify that if you think of
morality from a scientific perspective
you can't justify that when you think
from an individualistic perspective how
can selflessness be a good thing I am
Here I am Alive it's it's me shouldn't I
care about my life as the as the stand
if I'm if there's no God that I have to
that I have to you know adjust myself to
that the baby is our is a higher power
more important to me isn't my life the
most important thing in the universe to
me right and then based on that
shouldn't I then think okay
what are the values and virtues that my
life requires and that's it that I would
argue is a scientific question we have
to look at the world and see what works
for human being what doesn't violence
clearly doesn't work it's very
destructive reason you know every human
achievement every value everything we
have is a product of reason as I say
okay so if I care about my life what I
need to pursue more than anything else
is reason is is is my ability to
understand the world and then to try to
shape the world you know to make it
possible for me to live in it so I won't
presume to speak for any of those guys
either I tie both of them on a show but
so the other argument that that what I
thought was interesting so the Prager
argument in this case is that basically
on the macro level sorry on the micro
level that yes we can have atheists and
non-believers and we can all pick our
own morality and that's all okay but
whose argument really is that on a
societal level that you need this
outside force basically to temper the
parts of humans that get out of control
sort of I so you've already sort of
answered this but is there anything you
want to kind of yeah I think it's a very
bleak view of human nature and I think
that many many kind of people who are
generally secular but really believe in
religion have you know without religion
the war you know I can do without
religion but if those people don't have
life they will all become murderous
crazy people
I don't have that view of human beings I
mean I respect every individual and I
view every individual is capable of
understanding that going on a on a
murderous rampage is not good for them I
think that if we educated people well
and if we held up high expectation
people would understand that stealing
lying and cheating is not good for them
that the negative consequences that they
would bear would far exceed any
superficial benefit they might get from
it and when I explain to audiences look
line just is a stupid survival strategy
it just doesn't work it's not good for
you it's not good for you
psychologically and Jordan Peterson
that on this show has some wonderful
segments on lying and what it does to
psychologically is a psychologist talk
about that so psychologically its
destructive exist entually nobody wants
to deal with you once you're caught you
always caught right or ultimately you
always got it just is a bad strategy so
what I want to do is say look people
instead of having to go to another power
or instead of saying there is no
morality or saying well well it's
subjective whatever it whatever you feel
like I want to say let's use the same
tools that we use to evaluate other
things in likely to accept objective
let's yes use those tools the tools of
reason to evaluate what leads to a
successful life and and and and we might
disagree on some of those but at least
let's accept that the tool to evaluate
that is reason let's evaluate you know I
think we'll all agree that lying is not
good freedom of life so don't lie I
think we'll all agree that facts a
better than fall so - that's so honesty
is a broad concept which is not just
being honest other people but being
honest to yourself right we have to
agree what the facts are which is
becoming an increasing problem but sure
but how we approach what are facts that
is a question of epistemology it's a
question of science if you will let's
let's let's deal with it like that I
think we can we could probably agree on
that so let's approach ethics from that
basis but let's start with the idea that
it's the individual has to survive it's
individual that has to thrive and it
turns out that in order for me to thrive
me thriving does not entail me
exploiting you me through ieaving does
not it tell me lying and cheating and
stealing and murdering you quite the
contrary
me surviving and tells me trading with
you me it meets rising entails me
creating as many win-win mutually
beneficial situations as I can but not
because I love you like I love me I
don't I don't as much as I love you I
don't live here I feel warmly but I love
myself more this whole idea of love thy
neighbor I like yourself forget it
nobody loves their neighbor like they do
this so how many was self esteem loves
being able like they do so then I asked
Eve my Christian audiences asked them
okay your kids are joining in the pool
the neighbors kids are drawing new pool
who do you say first anybody saves their
own
kids first and I say you shouldn't be
embarrassed about that fact you should
be proud of the fact that your kids you
love them more than your neighbors kids
it's okay to save them first could I
would also try to save the neighbors
kids but only after I saved mine
I don't even know that this is totally
relevant but could that desire be from
something that supersedes logic could
that simply just be something that's
caked into us well you know through
genes and evolution and everybody not
clearly matter I mean this is part of
the big quite an interesting scientific
question what is actually baked into us
I can't think less is baked into us and
a lot of scientists today think but I
think that's a scientific question that
needs to be worked out but but yeah to
some extent look we love our kids
otherwise don't have them right because
you're not going to treat them well if
you don't love them so we love our kids
and when we love something we want to
protect it we want to embrace it we
wanted you know save it when it's in
harm's way we love like our neighbors
kids but it's just not going to be the
same so now it is true that there are
people you know there are mother Teresa
like people who will commit these acts
that know they'll let their kids die and
save the strangest kids because that's
the right thing to do now I view that as
awful
maybe that is evil right that you would
not take your life seriously enough to
save your kids will for the neighbors
but there are some people and and we
usually save them we usually you know
rather great honors who are willing to
sacrifice their life they values
everything they hold dear truly for the
sake of a stranger for the sake of know
sometimes for the sake of nothing and
that's what religion does to people and
that's one of the things I think is a
hollow ball about religion is it
inculcates this idea that there has to
be something greater than yourself so
with all that said then what do you do
about the religious people because if I
was to take I don't want a new atheist I
think it attacked a lot often unfairly I
think because people just pick there
they think that they're so mean and
they're trying to destroy religion and
they hate religious people I very rarely
have ever seen that I think they attack
the ideas of religion which is you know
I would say should be attacked or like
any other idea there is
but going under this this Objectivist
ideology what do you do with the
religious well how do they fit into a
society because I don't think you're
trying to exterminate them or even fully
they're certainly not the people but but
even the ideas of religion I don't sense
that you you'd prefer I suppose that
they start crumbling but not know I want
to be crawl there's no question I want
them to crumble I don't try to be nice
as I know you and I know but I know I
want them gone and but there's only one
way to do that and that's education
education education to speak it's that
it's the reason with people and and I
think my whole project everything I
believe in is to some extent dependent
on the demise of religion uh you know I
don't think without the Enlightenment
and at the beginning of the demise of
religion in the 18th century you would
have had a United States of America I
think the United States of America is a
secular achievement I mean counter to
all the religious right you claim it's
that it's the culmination of a
judeo-christian there's nothing
judeo-christian about them you know the
road to Texas on a dinosaur yeah and in
the Old Testament of individual rights
and the right to life liberty and
happiness I mean it's not there right it
this is the this is the achievement of
human reason of secularization of the
idea of relegating religion to your
private life which is a which
politically is enough right so we can
have a free society if we say religion
is relegated and you can't bring it into
the public square but that never happens
right the evangelicals are not just
going to sit there and say we're never
going to go into politics as we see
today and as we've seen for last 40 50
years they're very involved and they
were in the 19th century very involved
in political life so and they bring
religion into the public square I think
and I also the other thing is I'm not in
this for politics right politics is is a
is is the outcome it's great if we get
to live in a really free society that
would be so cool I mean much more
important as what we started out the
conversation with does the impact I can
have and these ideas can have on an
individual human being in making that
individuals like better so to me the
Objectivist ethics the Objectivist Moll
code is much more important to me than
all the politics and capitalism and all
this the suffrage the capitalism is just
an outcome of that so I partially I want
to see
my village because I want to free those
religious people from what I think of
barriers to their own success in their
own happiness and partially because I
think that the truly free society cannot
exist as long as a significant number of
people take their religion seriously I
think we'll Legion is anti-freedom at
its core and the more seriously they
take their religion or less free will be
so so I want to get rid of religion but
I realized that that's good gonna take
forever it's going to take a long long
time decades centuries maybe in the
meantime it convinced as many people as
I can
it bring in easily aside people writing
to me and they sign it Christian
objectivism and then I have Jewish
objectives the Hindu everybody thinks
they religion and objectivism of the
same right I can buy so my view is I'd
rather have you being a Christian
Objectivist than a Christian Christian
right I'd rather have you adopt certain
ideas from objectivism into your
Christian framework and then not adopt
any of the ideas so to the extent that I
can they can impact people's lives even
if they don't embrace everything that I
say right and it's a little spooky if we
sit here and talk and somebody says yeah
I agree I've never heard of your honor
everything you're on just said right I
go go go read a little bit go study
right because all I'm trying to do to
you and in my public talks is just get
people thinking yeah and then if they
read and then one day they come to the
conclusion I was right cool but I you
know people are convinced by one lecture
one talk I didn't it's scary to me a
little bit because if I don't that
Association thing is kind of funny
because the phrase well I don't agree
with everything he says I thought people
say that all the time now implying that
if you even say something nice or you
like a tweet of someone obviously
endorse everything that they've ever
said ever so I appreciate that you're
saying that but I but I know you're not
just saying it because I've been to
several these events that you guys put
on in it and colleges and I said we're
going to do a whole bunch to come this
fall but the the wide variety of people
in diversity of thought there was plenty
of diversity and all the other stuff too
but in the diversity of thought so it
wasn't as if well those objectives they
only said they were doing most of their
who said they
we're believers well I've talked to most
of people I think 90% of the people that
I actually speak in front of know either
don't know anything about what I'm going
to say or violently disagree hopefully
how violently but they disagree
intellectually fundamentally with what I
say and I just have to say I enjoy
speaking to hostile audiences much more
than I enjoy speaking to objectives on
ok you know they can agree with what I
said I can push the envelope a little
bit here a little bit there I can
stimulate them a little bit but to see
an audience that comes in hostile and
and at the end of the day is a little
respectful of the ideas because I said
something and I've said it in a way that
resonates with them and they go alright
so maybe I need to think about this
again that to me is so much more fun and
so much more interesting and so much
more world-changing at the end then just
talking to the converted if you will and
talking to people so I love I love the
challenge by young people I love going
to universities and having people really
go after me and there's videos online
and videos online you can find them and
you can tell that I'm enjoying it I
really get into it but yeah I mean it's
it makes it fun for me right I want to
be challenged I once I keep telling on
instance I want you to come up with a
question I've never heard before
yeah I want I want to be pushed because
it's not fun stagnating even if you
think you know even if you think what
you're saying is true you don't want to
stagnate tonight you want to keep
pushing the envelope yeah and even this
just idea out there that somehow
Objectivists or serious or whatever but
we did that in that there's video of it
500 people not only did I have everyone
cheering and screaming and standing up
and go crazy they were we did this whole
funny thing about the seven dirty words
George Carlin I don't know that ever has
thrown at me and I had everyone
screaming all did all the words and all
that and but it goes more to the point
that I think people are just starved for
some reality these days just having fun
yelling out some curses and it being
okay let's sort of forgotten how to just
be okay with but there is a bit of
craziness there's this perception that
if you an advocate for reason if you're
rational and believe in silence they
should've stuck up your ass and you
don't believe you know I love emotions
right I'm a passionate guy but I love
sitting value just listening to music
and just feeling
you know you live you experience in life
through your emotions and and you got to
value your emotions you got to cultivate
your emotions you got to really you got
to really experience your emotions
emotions are not just just not tools of
cognition you don't discover facts you
don't discover truth emotionally that's
what you use reason for but it doesn't
mean you demean your emotions you put
down your emotions it means you know
their place in your life emotions don't
have to do with truth maybe truth about
me but not truth about the world out
there reason to discover truth you just
need to know what part of yourself is
responsible for what
so Objectivists who understand the
philosophy and many of them don't many
of them I mean a lot of jokes out there
a lot of people use the philosophy to be
jokes but Objectivists to a
well-integrated
emotional people you know because they
they they understand that the important
role in Motion's playing human life
so you have been bouncing all over the
world I'm honored that you stopped in LA
during this world tour in Detroit
quickly and just name some of the places
that you've been just in the last few
months I mean you have really been all
over the place
well just in the last few months I I did
a tour of Asia I did I went around the
world yeah you're good over there so I
went for California I went to Tokyo
Kyoto Seoul South Korea to play a long
view in Beijing in China woollen Baja in
Mongolia Hong Kong Tel Aviv London
Clemson University which I know you're
going to go to in the in the fall and
then back to California and spoke it
every one of those places gave talks to
all in there people in all of those
spaces passionate I've also been as we
talked about too many places in Eastern
Europe I'm heading back to Tbilisi which
in Georgia I'm glad Baku in Azerbaijan
but I've been to I've been many times on
I'm going back to Kiev and to Warsaw in
to Krakow in to Sofia Bulgaria and I was
in Albania and in Montenegro and
Macedonia you know with most people so
many Americans don't even know where
they are on the map but I have my
audience with things you're making up
words right now yeah I hope that we know
I'm really doing
I want to stop there because I'm glad
you mentioned you said you're because
that's where I wanted to go with this
because you mentioned to me a couple
weeks ago that you're finding that in
Eastern Europe right now they're
incredibly receptive to these ideas
because they've had so many bad ideas
for so long test they no longer can
tolerate bad ideas or that they're
starving this lobby for something that
they know what they have is long right
so what they sow within memory within a
couple of generations may be sweet rate
they have fascism they've lived under
the Nazis they've had communism a brutal
communism right I mean their parents
were oppressed by communism and now they
just have corruption
they have no aqua see they vote but the
sense generally in Eastern Europe is the
government is corrupt they everything is
is cronyism people and and they look at
the West and they see America they see
Germany they see England they know
what's possible in terms of wealth they
know it's possible in terms of freedom
and and they they want that and and
they're looking for what it is that
leads to that and they know that the
alternative and they look at the
European Union and the suspicious of
that to centralize power autocratic
bureaucratic dictating from the top down
so they are I my sense in those places
and I'd add Brazil and some of the Latin
American countries to this as well
they've experienced so much holler over
the last hundred years that young people
you know college age people high school
early 20s looking for something
different and they'll open to new ideas
they're willing to be challenged you
cannot going to buy into the Marxist
garbage they're not going to buy into
silencing free speech because it's been
there done that
right so when you come to them and talk
about freedom when you come to talk to
them about real personal responsibility
taking your life seriously pursuit of
happiness they are open in ways that a
rich complacent college kid in the
United States isn't right Marxism sounds
kind of cool I've never experienced it I
don't know any histories I don't know
what it's done in the world right and I
don't even understand the role of ideas
and how ideas actually impact actions so
what the hell and and I'm really worried
about the next iPhone
and whether it's going to have the
features I really want but I hate
capitalism right you know capitalism is
evil but iPhone oh my god I need that
and Twitter and they also get over the
fact that it's made in China with people
paid very little yeah they attack me at
my Congress as they read even question
on the iPhone right they attack me so
for praising Apple and then they they go
after the Chinese workers but they're
using their phone they have no there's
no respect for the even ideas that they
hold because if they were true Lee held
those ideas they give up diaphragm
they'd give up the Samsung because the
same thing with Samsung they wouldn't
use one on technology because their
ideas are not consistent with modern
technology but the complacent life is
too good right life is too comfortable
and and I add so it's complacency in the
one hand the other thing you notice is
this our educational system in the
United States it's hard to express how
bad it really is it is anti thinking it
is anti really using one's mind it is in
it's it's it's all about emotion it's
all about cultivating emotion not as a
way of living but as experience life but
as a tool of cognition it's knowing
really what you feel is true I mean you
see that on the free speech debate that
is a big part of the free speech to be
feelings are truths and the world is no
objective reality to whatever I want it
to be whatever I feel it to be
that's the post-modernism that's a
culmination of it so it but that's in
our educational system that's deeply
rooted and as you go when you sit down
six-year-old and ask them what they
think about what they feel about Trump
what is the six-year-old know about
politics I mean six-year-old should not
be exposed to politics apparently a lot
of the pundits on Twitter their children
know these incredible essays and have
such incredible insight into trouble my
kid just said and then they lay out
something that's obviously the kids but
in a class we ask these kids for
opinions about topics that they know
nothing about right you have to have
life experience you have to have
knowledge you and if you don't have an
educational system so looking back to
Eastern Europe the educational systems
in Europe not just in Eastern Europe but
even the UK and so in Asia
just better than Alice so the kids know
more they know I get how did they get
education systems right if they got so
much fun oh I didn't say they got it
right or not right they're bad ok better
so what I would say is the educational
system in the world was at a certain
level
going into the 20th century and the
United States adopted progressive
education and went like that went down
right and the rest of the world kind of
punched around in mediocrity which is
where I think they are today so their
educational system a mediocre they're
not good fair bit but their mediocre
house is a catastrophe because we took
James Dewey seriously
so we input waste because he was the
first American philosopher everything
else came from Europe finally we found
an American who spoke philosophy we just
embraced him and made in one of any any
any espacio as a pragmatic philosophy
which appeal they gets to some extent of
Americans were action oriented rather
than intellectual early in it so we
embrace this idea of progressive
education which was focused on
socializing kids not on teaching them
and not on knowledge so I think the
British system in the European system is
bad because it's too regimented and in
it but it but what it's good at is
conveying knowledge the American system
doesn't convey knowledge it lets kids
bet if you're exceptional you do very
well in that system because you learn
yourself and then you're allowed to
innovate so that's why you get I think
the Steve Jobs is the the real
innovators the Silicon Valley types
because it's not regimented and one of
the reasons and that so what you need is
a well calibrated I wouldn't say middle
ground but but what you need is a system
that both conveys knowledge and allows
individuals the children to innovate to
think freely to experiment with ideas so
you mentioned that your passion really
is not the political side of this but
the philosophical side does ultimately
it feeds into everything that becomes
political so what would the right amount
of government be in your estimation
because I hear this all the time also
that well Objectivists are just sort of
fant they're sort of fancy libertarians
or something like they're libertarians
that may be excited through a little bit
more or somewhat those hands will say
objective this or liver
haven't thought about it is yes yes so
what in your view would be the rule well
I don't I don't want to I don't want to
position ourselves necessarily versus
libertarians I mean I think what more
philosophical and libertarians
libertarians and but I also don't know
what libertarianism means I think that's
the biggest problem it's a big tent
which includes an algo capitalist some
of them nice and alkyl capitalist like
buying Kaplan who was on this show some
of them not very nice anarcho-capitalist
the real really bad guys in my view and
we do a lot of damage to Liberty
movement all the way to people who are
kind of conservatives who want a big
role for government as compared to what
I would want they still consider
themselves Republican libertarian so to
me the whole libertarian thing is kind
of being Inglis so I believe that
government has only one rule and
everything needs to be measured on that
and that is to protect the rights of
individuals to protect your right to
life that's the core right to protect
the ability of individuals to pursue the
rational values they need to know to
live and to thrive and to be happy in
the end of the day so what does that
entail well protect them against what
right
well the criminals that are going to
steal your wallet are going to punch you
in the face you're going to murder you
will rape you they're always going to be
people like that right so you need some
protection entity and that entity is
government it has a monopoly over the
use of italia' to reach force the data
protect you from the criminals so when
ancap say even that can be privatized
that's somewhere where you say we
absolutely not it cannot be privatized
because that is legitimizing violence
that's saying violence oh we can have a
market in violence we can trade in
violence so it's a rejection of the idea
that violence has no place in civilized
humanity they view it just as another
market good I view it as a different
type of thing okay it's the anti reason
so if you focus on the positive which is
reason forces the anti reason has to be
excluded but more than that what the
inalco caps are saying is the truth what
is right about property rights how we
define property rights truth is
something to be negotiated between
protection agencies and objective says
no truth is something to be discovered
by people responsible for discovery
- so what are the boundaries of certain
types of property rights which are hard
right intellectual property rights which
are dollar of an alkyl capitalist reject
the role of governments the finals it's
it's the it's the set boundaries of what
they actually mean and and if you
disagree with them then that's what you
have a court system and that's what you
have a judiciary system but but at the
end of the day they have to be experts
who define certain things about so you
need a legislature and then so to define
but it's very now it's the protect
property rights in fact individual
rights and then you need a military to
protect us from bad guys invaders
terrorists or whatever but that's it so
you know what about roads and pull and
postal service and things like so all
the postal service I mean I mean does
anybody use the postal service anymore
yeah so you will go for privatizing that
I just want to get some of the total of
that level privatized suddenly roads
could be privatized the whole books
written on how to do it I'm not an
expert on privatizing roads and I think
it's the last thing that we need to deal
with but it but I don't think it's that
hard particularly with modern technology
to privatize roads and to charge a fee
for usage on roads and these are easy
things I ate I think the challenging
stuff that people talk about is health
care and things like that which I don't
think is challenging because I think I
think the only reason it seems
challenging to people's they lack
imagination but III ask how would it be
not challenging I can't let you look at
healthcare so easy but you know I'll get
to it right yeah okay so I ask audiences
all the time um and I have to use mine
oh he took my iPhone I don't have an
iPhone week okay I don't - ah my eyes
when I can't use it as a prop yeah and
you ask audiences will pretend you have
an iPhone here I think so here's the
iPhone right yes would you want this
design by government committee what
would it look like if it was and
everybody freaks out of course now we
don't know don't let it touch that right
that's okay
what's more important health care or the
iPhone mahalik is one point why would
you let an entity would not design an
iPhone why would you let them design
health care system why would you let
them dictate you know what doctors to
see and what treatments to get why would
you let a bunch of bureaucrats who can
design an iPhone a simple product like
an iPhone deal with the human body
which has have a million times more
complex or with education I use the same
example education I don't want to go and
touching education because it's it's too
much for them it's not what they'd able
to do why would you want the institution
responsible for force using guns to come
into a hospital
I don't want guns in hospitals I don't
want guns in schools right I'm gonna get
the Second Amendment guys after better I
don't want right I don't want a big
government and I think when I see
government I see a gun
I see force I see coercion I see
Authority the only place authority
belongs is to protect from people with
guns that's it I don't want that that
that use of force anywhere else so what
is the solution the solution is to
privatize it the solution is to bring
the same kind of innovation imagination
entrepreneurship into the healthcare
space that we have at Silicon Valley
right imagine if if doctors view
themselves as entrepreneurs and if
insurance companies could offer any
product in the world that they you would
have an economist could you know come up
with these you would have insurance
against pre-existing conditions you can
buy a product like that it wouldn't be
that hard you have all kinds of
definitions
I could call I could customize insurance
policy from me and I would I would use
the marketplace to figure out what
treatments I wanted and didn't want when
that prices would be clearly
identifiable so the solution to
healthcare the problems are we have
today know is more freedom just like
that's the solution to any economic
issue it's it's free up the
entrepreneurial mind free up the
creators and the builders and the makers
so what though would you do about all of
the people that just simply can't afford
to get in the game so using your iPhone
analogy obviously not everyone can
afford an iPhone there's going to be a
certain amount of people no matter what
now I understand before Obamacare we
took care of them at at the emergency
room and it was not nice it's crazy and
now we have it we have a different
situation but what you have to kiss real
market would how those people there's a
question that they would look what so
before bamaca 30 million Americans
supposedly couldn't afford health care
to buy to buy health insurance
and the end the question was why and if
you looked across states and you looked
at the various insurance products in
states like California which regulated
to death exactly what an insurance
company could offer I have to pay for
pregnancy and maternity and acupuncture
I try to activate you I don't like it
never going to use it and a million
other things that are covered money
chance is incredibly expensive but like
there are states and I can't tell you
the exact which ones but in states that
you could go to and get a simple policy
that covered your emergencies and cost
less than a cellphone bill now how many
Americans can afford a cell phone almost
not ninety seventy percent of Americans
have cell phones and pay their bill on
time and do and do something like that
it health insurance should be affordable
to anybody and it could be affordable to
anybody if you've got all these
regulations and all these constraints
and then if you encourage competition
with insurance companies one of the
problems is we have two or three
insurance companies that dominate the
field but that's because they can only
sell a particular package when you
commoditize insurance you get
monopolization what you need is to deep
get rid of the commodity aspect of let
competition ring let people come up with
new innovations and then you get real
competition what does competition do
everywhere in every field drive prices
down and drive quality up and that's and
if you did that there would be nobody
I'm not going to say nobody would have
no insurance somebody with some young
person would say had only to buy
insurance I'm young and I'm
indestructible and you know what and a
certain sliver of people that simply
still cannot so the sliver couldn't
afford it so what do you do with those
people I mean I would say I'd say the
main thing you do with those people is
you provide them with a safety net but
that safety net should be provided
privately and not a government a
government shouldn't decide who gets to
be part of the safety net who doesn't we
should decide and again I ask every
audience there's a video of me doing
this at a school I say how many of you
want to take care a willing to take a
portion of your salary every month and
pay into a fund that takes care people
who really cannot take care of
themselves every hand in the room goes
up and say so what's the problem why do
we need a
and bureaucratic come with a gun and
collect the money from you when you are
happy to do it voluntarily and you all
see why it's good for you and it's good
for the world in which you want to live
to help those people who are following a
bad luck or who can't for whatever
reason take care of themselves right now
so we we create a private safety net now
I know I because we talked about this
last time and your listeners are very
cynical oh nobody would pay in that
stuff but that's just not true in the
19th century in America there was no
government safety net and this country
was relatively poor as compared with how
rich we are today and immigrants just
flooded that you think the illegal
immigrants from from Mexico some people
think our problem the lot of immigrants
that came into America in the 19th
century far exceeds anything that is
coming from Mexico as a per capita basis
they all found jobs or some of them
struggled and family helped them and
others struggled and the community
helped them but the government didn't
intervene and almost nobody I'm not
going to say nobody died in the streets
but almost nobody died of starvation in
the streets today with far richer
hmm we have you know patreon we have
mechanisms to raise money that have
never existed you know there's no
question about and we have these
billionaires who have you know the
amount of money that they have they're
not of wealth if that is unimaginable
the idea that in a culture like ours we
couldn't afford to take care of a few
people who really can't take care of
themselves is ludicrous to me the idea
that we need some government bureaucrat
to decide how much of our income we'll
have to donate to is there's a we I mean
maybe of that we've just been sort of
dumbed into the mission we've just
accepted at this point that this is how
it is so if you were to say to the
average person well would you give more
they'll say yes but then to actually
take the the notion of I'm going to now
vote for people that are going to make
that a reality is sort of a bridge too
far like it's more than that it's that a
lot of people say this and this so this
was released a lot of issues people will
say I would do it I know I would do it
but but they want it right and I've
talked to businessman who say I - knee
does not need to be regulated we're
honest we do it right
competition with bad industry there are
really bad people and they need to be
regulate down and and you see this
projection and this comes from a certain
cynicism about the world but it comes
from certain view of human nature which
again I'm trying to combat and I think
this goes to the core of I want people
to adopt this idea that we can be
rational that we can think for ourselves
that people can take care of themselves
99.9% of humanity can take care of
themselves can feed themselves can
clothe themselves can can deliver life
that is successful there few people
there for genetic reasons or whatever
born incapacitated or accidents happen
to them but if you look at a human being
out there they can take care of
themselves and what they need is to be
taught how and they need to be educated
and then we stop feeling sorry for
themselves and they need to get up on
their feet what a waste of a life to
moan and complain and bitching and
assume that everybody's a bad guy around
and waste like do something positive you
know make something of yourself and
whatever level of ability you have you
know some people have a low IQ or have
or not a strong or whatever whatever
realm you live in you can make something
of your life that's what that's what I'm
about and if you if that's what you want
in life then the system that makes that
possible as a system of freedom is a
system that is not going to place
artificial barriers in your pursuit of
life and as long as you're not hurting
other people you do what you do and you
know what you're going to fail sometimes
failure is part of life and when you
fail you can go to your neighbor and ask
for help and if you've been a nice guy
they will help you and if you've been a
rotten guy they might not help you
that's part of that's part of the
personal responsibility question here
right and you know take responsibility
for your own life live it don't expect
other people to be forced to help you
you don't ever like to pull a gun on
your neighbor and demand the help
somehow that gun goes away when we vote
to take money from our neighbors to help
us know if this is a great point right
some things involve for an individual to
do it
mall for the group to do so point iron
man make great
so if stealing is wrong then stealing is
wrong and it doesn't matter how many
times we vote on it doesn't matter how
many people vote on it it's still
stealing it's still taking using force
taking something away from me that
belongs to me so if we can just adopt
that simple principle right and if we
can if we can understand and people can
accept that person responsibility you
know that that's the hope I have
politically you know in for the future
Your Honor I usually like to offer
guests a chance to kind of sum up their
philosophy and do it in a nice little
bow you beat me to it I think I think
you beat me to it I do want to add
though before we end up as I said before
neck you know next time maybe I have
Shermer and pray grid we can get you
involved in something like that for now
before another perspective on but for
the record you have offered to debate
plenty of people that I've had on the
show we're going to do then Shapiro just
said that he's willing to do something
with you so we're going to do that and
see if we can mix this in because I
think the next evolution of the ideas
behind the show are having more of these
conversations yeah and as people can
discover on YouTube I've debated plenty
of people so it's not I don't I don't
shun the debating format I enjoy it and
and these of people I respect so even
though I disagree with many of them one
on many different issues I believe in
that dialogue I believe the only way to
actually move things forward is to
discuss the debate and to use as long as
we all accept the reason as the guide
truth and that's what we're going to
discover truth out there then and yeah
I'm bringing them on it's going to be a
lot of fun are you going to do any of
these events with me in the fall or
you're you're all over the world again
I'm all over the world again I'm
traveling this fall we'll do some events
on campus we'll make it happen all right
very good for more on your own follow
him on the Twitter machine at your own
Brooke
[Music]
you